breaking news here on the Sky News the
Chinese spy balloon which has been
spotted over the United States over the
past a couple of days has in the past
few minutes been brought down
supposition is it has been shot down
after an order from President Biden
himself you'll recall just after a
couple of hours ago that President Biden
has said he would take care of this
suspected spy balloon which is reported
to have been conducting surveillance on
the U.S military and it seems that
certainly has happened we know that
airspace was closed around 100 square
miles off the Carolinas uh number of
flights stopped following an order in
the past hour or so and that will prove
where the balloon had been heading it
was over North Carolina uh Charlotte a
couple of hours ago and it has drifted
so it seems to have been uh brought down
over water that is the supposition Mark
stone is our U.S correspondent who's
monitoring events live from the Pentagon
uh so it is down mark
very very significant developments uh
over the past five ten minutes or so I'm
looking at images here which I hope we
could bring to you at some point in the
next few minutes which show um the sky
and the white dots that is the balloon
that we have seen over the past couple
of days traveling across the continental
United States and a small plume of smoke
hits that white spot and then it appears
to deflate and begin to begin to come
down there is also some some Vapor
Trails of what look look like either a
military aircraft or perhaps a missile
uh in the same area as well
um what we do know as you say is that
President Biden in the past hour or so
gave the order to take the balloon down
he pretty much said as much when he was
asked by reporters a couple of hours ago
uh what the uh what he would do about
the balloon and he said we will take
care of it now that combined with the
fact that a no-tam order was put out
that's a notice to Airman anyone fly
buying in the area around Myrtle Beach
now Wilmington and Charleston in the
Carolinas um anyone in the air should
should get out of that particular bit of
airspace we then saw a uh there was only
one plane in that airspace and it was a
U.S Air Force plane so all of that
together
um brings us to this news that it does
appear to have been shot down or at
least taken out in one way or another so
so the effort now will be as we
understand to recover uh the the
wreckage of course we know from what the
Pentagon has told us over the past two
days that they were very wary about
shooting it down over land because this
is such a large balloon we understand
that the payload itself is the size of
of three buses so a very very large uh
thing that they needed to take down and
of course if it had come down over land
then there would be no guarantee that it
wouldn't hit anyone on the on the land
so so a decision has been made when it
had moved out it's off over American
land into the sea space that they would
take it down and it appears that's
exactly what they have done so so the
effort now will be to recover whatever
they can up from the sea and of course
that will from an American perspective
be highly valuable
um if the if the Chinese are right that
it was simply a weather balloon that
went off course well we'll soon find out
if that was the case uh or not um so
that appears to be what's happened and I
imagine there is a a situation room in
the Pentagon behind me where all of that
was carried out over the course of the
past few days the Pentagon has been
giving the White House options over what
to do their advice was don't shoot it
down over land but clearly that advice
has now changed politically for
President Biden uh there was a a dynamic
too because the president was under a
lot of pressure not to let this one pass
literally uh the the the idea from
certainly the rights of American
politics here that you could just let a
Chinese balloon float over America
taking pictures and Gathering
intelligence of whatever it wanted and
not do anything about it was just
something that just couldn't happen so
politically for the president there was
a a dynamic that he needed to to
consider and it appears he has made the
decision now to shoot it down of course
what we don't know is how the Chinese
will respond to this they had all the
the meeting with between Xi Jinping the
Chinese president and the U.S Secretary
of State that was canceled by the
Americans the Chinese admitted it was
one of their balloons they said it was a
weather balloon but now that the
Americans have actually taken it out we
will await to see what the reaction is
from Beijing where of course it is it's
it's uh it's late at night there but I
imagine some reaction will come fast